English lessons today's mini English
lesson is about verbs verbs followed by
other verbs verbs can be followed by the
infinitive to plus the base form to eat
for example or Gerrans
verb plus the ing eating so some verbs
are always followed by gerunds enjoy I
enjoy eating fresh croissants in the
morning and some verbs are always
followed by the infinitive I want to eat
eggs in the bacon today want is an
example of a verb always followed by the
infinitive but how do we know which ones
to use unfortunately for these verbs you
just have to learn them sorry
then there are a group of verbs that can
be followed by gerunds infinitives these
verbs a little bit more complicated
because there is a slight difference in
meaning I like oh I love eating
chocolate
or I love to eat chocolate with my
coffee in the morning if we say I love
eating it's more general but if I say I
love to eat then our specific moment the
last group of verbs are verbs that can
be followed by gerunds or infinitives
but the meaning changes quite a lot stop
stop
is an example that can be used by both
the difference is quite big I stopped
eating so much cake because I was
worried about my weight and I stopped to
eat another piece of cake here how do we
know what the difference in meaning is I
stopped eating we are looking backwards
at the event where as I start to eat is
looking forwards at the event let's just
recap there are three different types of
verbs that can be followed by other
verbs the first example we looked at
there are verbs that are always followed
by gerunds are always followed by
infinitives then there are those verbs
like lie and love
which are sometimes followed by one or
the other there is a little difference
in meaning but basically they are very
similar then we have those verbs like
stop who are very different meanings if
we use them with gerunds or follow them
by infinitives I think you should
remember to stop before you use a gerund
or infinitive after reverb next time
[Music]